Justin and Selena are at it again the
new pics meanwhile Britney and her
boyfriend are also packing on the PDA
plus we're with Ashanti did she once
have beef with Beyonce hi friends
welcome back to the daily Deni Justin
Bieber and Selena Gomez are gettin cozy
now that they are officially back on
looking at these latest photos I think
it's safe to say Jelena is going strong
check out the pair catching up over
dinner following midweek church service
Wednesday night now after ordering
refreshments and chatting for a bit
Justin was spotted leaning in for a long
hug and a kiss at the montage hotel in
Beverly Hills
while the two have yet to confirm their
relationship status a source told ETS
Lena and Justin are officially exclusive
and are excited to have reconnected not
to mention it seems Jelena can't stand
to be apart they are so inseparable
these days our et source added quote
they're together all the time they're so
happy and having so much fun together
okay guys here's the deal I have been
worried about these two linking up again
but they both seem to be in a good place
plus they are being qaf and I want to be
proven wrong but I'm gonna give them a
solid 6 to start on the John and Chrissy
scale there is room for growth okay
alright let's just hope they don't
suffer the same feat as one-time hot
young couple Justin Timberlake and
Britney Spears though I'd say both JT
and Britt have done pretty good for
themselves since then in fact Brit Brit
and her man model Sam asghari were
snapped courtside at the lakers Warriors
game Wednesday night when the action
turned to the stands as the couple
shared a sweet smooch Britney was also
there with her sons who seemed pretty
unfazed by moms PDA now staying on the
couple's train it seems Justin and
Selena aren't the only ones who have
rekindled their relationship it looks
like Chris Evans and Jenny slate are
back together
People magazine confirmed the couple are
dating again following their February
split after one year of dating now
rumors of a reconciliation have been
flying around after they exchanged some
flirty Twitter messages around that time
Jenny was also referencing her boyfriend
on social media and earlier this month
Chris share
this video of his pooch howling along to
a Disney classic but listen very
carefully because the woman's voice in
the background sounds an offering like
Jenny slate
[Music]
did you catch that listen I'm so on
board for them to to get back together
these two have not only remained friends
to their breakup but when they were
dating
they're pretty smitten here's what Jenny
told us what it was like to date Captain
America when he accompanied her to the
premiere of her movie secret life of
pets
let me see Chris is here supporting you
today what's so great about having him
out here for a special day like them I
mean this is for me I haven't really had
a very large premiere before so it's
nice having someone who sort of knows
how it goes and also honestly we're just
like both two teenagers from
Massachusetts so it kind of feels like I
got my dream seventh-grade boyfriend's
cute I raised an imaginary glass to
Chris and Jenny I am rooting for you
guys now speaking of drinking you rang
joining me now is my pal sobytia' lacy
with a new interviews under the
influence and it's a good one it is a
great one that is right princess Ashanti
joins me in studio to promote her new
partnership with Ciroc French vanilla we
had so much ground to cover Denny now if
you're unfamiliar with the interviews
under the influence series here's how it
works I ask the stars tough questions
cringe-worthy good I'm making shoes to
answer the question or plead the fifth
and drink but here's the thing
Ashanti did not hold back which is why I
asked her point-blank about that in 2003
New York Times review if you recall it
said that solo Beyonce is no Ashanti now
I got to throw it back to 2003 for this
question
what was your honest-to-god reaction
when you saw that infamous New York
Times Beyonce review
honest reaction Wow
we're going there I was just like wow
you know it was it was super flattering
what I didn't like so much is that the
media has a way of pitting people
against each other coerce her and I had
always had a very cool camaraderie it's
always like hey what's up how you doing
hey I like you sneakers come not wired
that way if I don't like you I don't
like you I could hate you and still like
your record you don't I mean and vice
versa I'm too happy with myself to just
be an envious kind of a person shot
enemy I hope you were thirsty so because
she pretty much answered everything you
asked she really did thank goodness that
cocktail was delicious too and I was
feeling it I also asked her point-blank
whether she had ever hooked up with her
longtime collaborator ja Rule thank you
and you know what she answered so you'll
have to find out what she said that
episode of interviews under the
influence is up right now on our channel
I love it thank you so so much go shake
off the booze are you guys don't want to
miss that or tomorrow's episode of daily
Denny so be sure to subscribe to et's
youtube channel and save this playlist
because tomorrow is new music Friday so
get ready
[Music]